est ce que tu es d'accord pour faire une
interview au but mais oui mais oui mais
[Musique]
j'ai joué dans des films pour 8 mai mais
j'ai bien l'intention de tourner avec
cédric klapisch
je ne travaille pas pour l'argent mais
mais en tant que personnes d'obédience
judaïque je me suis intéressé par tout
ce qu'elle a toujours l'aspect financier
évidemment je peux lui trop d'impôts
mais mais plus on en gagne plus on en
panne et moi là je ne crois pas en dieu
mais mais quand même j'aimerais bien
qu'ils croient en moi
[Musique]
les russes mari elle réagissait sur je
paye trop d'un oui c'est sympa
sur l'interview d'un autre mec à vous
avez tant prison
je je je
ici je t'aime apprécie pas
particulièrement les partouzes mais à
mai mais je ferais bien un petit tour au
bristol
je suis une star chez les gays mais je
suis une star chez les gays moi bien sûr
c'est vrai vous aime bien mais à choisir
je préfère prendre une jeunette je peux
te faire chier avec toute la communauté
là tu crois que il fait que j'avoue que
j'aimerais bien me faire attraper
éventuellement ça arrange les affaires à
élargir et mon fils
je ne suis pas jaloux mais mais quand
même ça m'ennuierait de savoir que tu as
un mec amaizing à ce que j'ai un mec
d'antoine soir quand on laisse l'est de
mystery writers better the mystery of
course
ok ok bonus ils apprennent single ce
soir une doble je ne suis pas de droite
mais mais je suis de gauche
j'ai une toute petite [ __ ] mais ah bon
tiens je vais visage et ses mains je
m'abstiens les gêne par rapport à wendy
c'est vrai il y avait ce mot le dic des
bottes aux sapeurs de la non pas qu'elle
commence à s'allonger s'éloigne je dors
arthur mai mais j'aime bien y sont aussi
ah ouais
on ne sait pas ce qu est un gros con
mais ya pas de même mais comment vous le
savez
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu